a problem for me
Jun kyung Etc
how would you pronounce it
how do you pronounce it
okay and he will talk about some
graphics
thank you very much for the introduction
and uh yeah it's my great pleasure to be
here
um and I would especially thank the
organizers for this great Workshop which
I've been waiting for the last two years
yeah um so I'm going to talk about some
recent developments on graph Norms
um so as you all know in the theory of
10 scrap limits I mean it's the theory
of limit so
um it's there should be some Metric or
known on the space so and as you all
know this caught Norm
um it specially provides the code metric
which is a standard metric in the theory
of 10 square of limits
um so and another key parameter in the
theory of dense verb limits is again
um the homomorphism density which I
denote by th P sub h and yeah this is
one of the key theorems in the theory
which says that the sequence of graphs
is convergent if and only if the H count
converges for every age right and having
seen the importance of these H counts it
is kind of natural at least for me
um to ask can a single H count give a
norm that can that may replace this code
Norm I mean if we can having seen the
importance it's for me uh it's natural
to wonder
um if such a replacement is possible on
the vector space of symmetric functions
and yeah so this was actually answered
at least partially in 80s so the famous
Chong Graham Wilson theorem which your
functions are not bounded right
[Music]
I mean it's
let's say about let's say
yeah it's possible to like extend it to
like LP but yeah for safety let's say
it's fun yeah
okay
um yeah so this was the Chong Graham
Wilson theorem which is
um phrased slightly differently in terms
of this language
so
the Tom Graham Wilson theorem basically
says that we can replace this chord Norm
by using the even cycle counts
um and yeah these are the even Cycles
and yeah this is a Cornerstone in
chromatrix and
um
yeah one may ask why why is it so
special about the even cycle what's so
special about Stephen Cycles
um well here's some reasons some quick
reasons
um because they corresponds to these
Norms in the Spectrum so if you consider
this symmetric Matrix and you look at
the Spectrum and yeah and that just
corresponds to the l2k norm of the
Spectrum which we often call Stratton
Norms or chattan for Neumann Norms yeah
so this is a very brief reason and yeah
as I said this fact this phasic fact is
a Cornerstone in the theory of
quasi-randomeness and this also inspired
lots of
work by um
work by um dollars proof of examin at
this theorem
um for example the governor's norms
right so the previous one of the case
32k is the length of the even cycle
yeah we need all event Cycles uh no just
just yeah just single even cycle this I
don't understand this at all so you're
saying if I have to subgroup density of
one of them I'm done in identifying the
graph
[Music]
so what I'm saying is you can basically
yeah so what you're you want to say is
you compared to breakfast say you know
by using the Cutler and this can be
completely replaced by using say six
cycle account okay to identify them okay
yeah okay
to use
but if not give me the distance
it won't give you the distance
between I mean these these two nodes are
technologically okay
yeah and the quantitative equivalence is
perfect
so sorry
you're not comparing the success as he
was asking if you're not comparing the
six cycle counts of two graphs you're
Computing this quantity for the
difference of these two grand funds and
minimizing overall rotations and so on
uh so I'm talking about enormous rather
than the the distance so let's just
saying what I'm saying is
um as I say
um yeah just replacing this cotton by
the six cut six cycle counts normal
lives
yes
yes
do you still take the energy value
inside this integral uh that's a great
question so
um you can or you can leave it like this
or you can take your absolute value here
or inside or you can um yeah you can
leave out the absolute values because
your assistance as you can see it's
always a non-negative number
yeah that's the 2K power of some reels
so that's always normal
yeah either
so could you just clarify so you're
saying if two graph funds General graph
funds of the same density of six Cycles
this implies they're the same no no no
okay yeah
I see okay pretty things
uh so
um having the same six type of account
doesn't necessarily mean that the
reference are the same pretty good so
what are you doing yeah
yeah I subjected too so it's different
from comparing the six types of
something here and six type content here
to me yes so that goes to zero then
yeah it's a number of six cycles of w
minus Capital Prime is zero that W
equals W yes yeah that is true
by waiting seconds by the point
okay
is there anything special about six or
will it work for a large reports for all
events yeah yeah as as I say uh this
itself is a norm and the Spectrum and
hence it also defines the normally
Regional space yes which we approach
thank you
okay can I move on
confusion I think you're still confusing
people
uh
so the question is what's so special
about even Cycles can you do can you use
different graphs to do the same thing
like this I just replace this six cycle
by some general h
uh so this is the question but to
formalize this question let me just be
precise as much as possible
um do us a favor why don't you write out
let's say the four cycle in terms of an
integral source that we see explicitly
what you're doing so okay yeah and I
think that may help people with so
confusing
and use a new marker
yeah this seems to be work
so and W is just some function okay yeah
and if you think of w as an operator
then this is the trace of w to the power
4.
okay if the trace of w to the power 4 is
0 then W must be zero as an operator and
if it's zero as an operator then W must
be zero
yeah thanks for the help
yes so here's a question and
um yeah let me just
foreign yeah let me let me just
um elaborate so on the vector space of
the symmetric functions the symmetric Bo
functions on the unit Square we want to
find H such that
either this which we take the absolute
value outside of the H count and or we
we can take the absolute value inside
the H count just like we do for these
usual LP Norms we can just replace each
of these W's in terms of their absolute
values yeah so there are two different
concepts that we can take and the letter
one being a norm is a weaker property so
from now on what I'm going to say is if
this defines a norm then H is normal and
if that the latter one defines a norm
then I'm going to say h is weekly Noni
because the letter one is a weaker
property
okay so here's lotsy
um who asked the question so he asked uh
what graphs are norming and later on
um
um yeah when hatami started uh what
graphs are norming he also asked what
graphs are weakness and I would say this
is a beautiful question where
communatorics line algebra function
analysis I mean you already seen quite a
bit right and probability and even group
Theory meant so yeah uh yeah the purpose
of my talk is partially to like convince
you that this is a beautiful question
where lots of areas
okay so sorry our bipartite graphs a
good candidate uh yeah so he's asked who
has a bipartite graphs a good candidate
yes
um the fear for anybody online or is
this an exercise in futility
okay I think if people are online they
could speak up and we can hear them so
is anybody online
I'm online I'm waving good thank you so
it's not a futile exercise we do it for
you yeah you do it for me and I'm
listening and I'm very appreciative and
I like your comments Christian you've
been making very interesting comments
all the way through
is
okay
yeah
so one of the motivations why we study
this question is the famous conjecture
of zerenko which is also conjectured by
Addison schmonovitz in a slightly
different form
um yeah it states the following let H be
any bipod type broth then this
inequality holds for any graph on W
right so what what does it mean
um that means the H count is minimized
by the the random graph basic or
sympotically minimized by the random
graph GNP with the same density if we
fix the density and if we want to
minimize the number of bipartite graphs
then the choice must be the random graph
so let's say if this inequality holds
for all graphones W then H gives
stirenko
um there are lots of theoretical graphs
are known including my results with
various colleagues
um well but
it remains open and the smallest open
case so far is this one the K5 by minus
C10 which we call the mobile strip and
this was actually the one of the
examples suggested by sirenko himself in
this 1992 paper but still no one ever
managed to either approve or disprove
that this graph is syllenko or not so
it's a very frustrating
Infamous example
and here's an application of the weekly
learning property
um so every weekly nomic graph is
cedarenko and in fact a much stronger
correlation inequality than this crinkle
property
holds so this is a observation by palash
recorded in hatami's paper
saying if H is weak looming then for
every subgraph F you have this
inequality in particular if you take
your app as a single edge then you have
the Citroen course property
okay so and there are other graphs than
um weekly Nomine graphs that satisfies
this very strong correlation inequality
which we call dominating graphs
um yeah so I included this result
um
just to motivate myself and probably
David
um to write it up quickly yeah so yeah
for example you can prove the same
inequality for every even length path
which has been known since
um I think 90s or 80s
um yeah by the work of uh air Editions
okay um so this is one motivation and
um let's have a look at some sufficient
conditions for this weeklynoming or
norming properties right so
um here are some results known so hatami
um in this 2010 paper proved that hyper
cues are weaklynoming and the complete
bipartite drops with M vertices and N
vertices on each side are also
weakenoming and if both are even then
it's norming
um yeah this is what hatami proved and
he also rediscovered this result by
Chong Graham Wilson about even psychos
in terms of this language
he proved in his book so there is a
chapter 14 which covers pretty much
about this stuff uh that he uh where he
proved that ktt minus a perfect matching
so this is one example so I took k55 and
then removed one perfect matching okay
so these are weekly Nomi and this was uh
generalized by myself with David
um saying that any reflection graphs
which I'm gonna Define
um in a few minutes
every week clean every reflection graph
is weaken domain and there's a stronger
notion
that we call stable reflection graphs
which are normally so this for example
includes all these known examples so far
and I add many more for example the one
subdivision of octahedron or the one
subdivision of complete graphs yeah
these are all examples one of these are
two examples and it also includes all
the incidence graphs of regular polytops
you can also replace the regular
polytops by a Simplex saying
um if you build a bipartite graph with K
sets on one side and the r sets on the
other side and you draw an edge if the
rset contains a case set yeah if you
consider such a bipartite graph which we
call set inclusion graph then it's also
an example
and here are some necessary conditions
um so yeah as you ask
um the these weakenoming graphs are uh
necessarily bipartite because
um it's a bit of Overkill but it's
necessarily stillerenko and Theodore
ankle graphs are necessary bipartize
and moreover
um well let me just recall that um this
we call this fact that every weakenomen
graph is the wrinkle and hatami also
showed that it must be bi-regular which
means it's a bipartite graph so you have
two parts and at each side you see the
same degree for every vertex so it's by
regular and myself with prede Garber and
Jan plotkey if it's disconnected then
all its components must be isomorphic so
it's a very symmetric graph and one good
thing here is that by using this theorem
we can always assume there are
weakernoming graph is connected
later on cedarenko proved that it must
be Edge transitive so it's a very
symmetric class of graph which we can
describe like this so every bipartite
Edge transitive graph is a G1 G2 G graph
say so what do I mean by G1 G2 G graph
it's a graph constructed by a group G
with two subgroups G1 and G2 so on one
side you just collect all these left
cosets of G1 and on the other side you
just collect left cosets of G2 and you
put an edge if they intersect
okay
actually this encodes all the bipartite
extensive graphs in terms of uh like
group theoretic language
and so here's a definition of the
reflection graph so reflection graph uh
due to myself and David is a G1 G2G
graph with very particular choice of
groups so here G must be the final final
real reflection group not even complex
and G1 and G2 are probably subgroups so
what do I mean by public subgroups it's
in so we have a company what is a
reflection group so
um yeah reflection group is a group
generated by hyperplanes it's a finite
group so due to the classical work of
[ __ ] sector we have a complete list of
binary reflection groups
um yeah and the probably subgroups are
generated by the standard
um generators which we call Simple
Reflections you can just think of some
hyper planes
um some standard hyper planes that
generates
um these groups can you be I mean maybe
I'm the only one who is not a group
theorist but otherwise could you draw
some pictures and are your hyperplates
in Rd or also have problems some
abstract top up what do you mean by
yeah how do you generate a group from it
and so on yeah so one example would be
you take the
um simplex
say
something like this and you can think of
the symmetries of the Simplex which
means
um you can consider uh the hyperplanes
which we uh which cut this Simplex into
the same half so this is one hyperplane
we can consider and there are other
hyperplanes like this
um or some some other hyperplanes like
these
yeah and so on and
um the reflections about the hyperplane
general us generators for you yes yes
yes yes yeah
and if I collect the the hyperplanes
that have
like that form
this chamber I would say so it this that
makes this triangle then these are
simple Reflections so these three
hyperplanes that
um yeah that surrounds this triangular
region they generate the whole group and
these These are the standard generators
of the
um the symmetric group which corresponds
to transpositions
yeah and if I take a subset of these
simple Reflections and generate the
subgroup out of it then it's so called
the probability subgroups
okay so
um yeah these are some necessary
conditions
and well the bad news here or good news
is no no these necessary conditions are
sufficient so due to the result by crowd
Martin Spock and rocna
yeah there exists a edge transitive
pseudo-rankograph that is not weakness
so even if we assume all of these as
transduced the wrinkle by regular
um I mean Edge Transit graphs are
necessary by regular but even if we
assume all of these it can be not weaken
only so here's the situation so we have
reflection drops
due to the result of myself with David
it's necessary these are weakenomen
graphs and weekly Nomine graphs are
necessarily Edge transitive but the
inclusion here is strict
okay and here's the ultimate goal which
is a conjecture of David saying that the
the examples we found here should be
[Music]
oh okay
uh this proves
um so there's
yeah you'll see some equivalent
conditions and um one of the equivalent
conditions is
um
uh but using convexity basically yeah
yeah so it's so called the step C rental
property which is substantially stronger
than the serial property yeah and uh
yeah then den and colleagues use this
property to
um like basically refuted condensity
so that's one way
yes so I mean to prove this is a great
conjecture
I was wondering is there anything
special about the left concept
um no you can use
one left concept one right call Set uh
that would be a different story uh I've
never
thought about it actually yeah but I
mean you can choose
left or right but
um one left and one right is a different
story it would give a different graph so
yeah I yeah I think that
possible yeah I suspect
yeah so
yeah so to prove this
um I mean one side is already
already there so if reflection graph
then we can know me or if stable
reflection graph then it's normal so we
need to prove the converse so
to just illustrate where we are so we do
know that
um
a weakenomic graph is actually
transitive which means it's a G1 G2 G
graph I described but the task is now to
nail down this G
to be the uh one of these lists of
finite reflection groups and G1 and G2
also should be this very special
probability subgroups so
but what's hard is I mean we are
basically dealing with some average so
this H count here is some some average
and this doesn't really contain any kind
of algebraic information about the
automorphism group of H I mean
it does contain something
but it doesn't contain many kind of
detailed
um information about the Automotive
Group yeah so
this is the hardest part
and yeah and this is the the ultimate
goal
okay so let me just describe this
property
um more properly by introducing some
equivalent conditions yeah so
recall that this is my age count so I
take
um this bunch of product of the the
function W and I just average or I just
take the integration and the following
are equivalent
so the first property is the definition
H if we can only and the second one says
this is a context parameter uh on this
convex set so it's it's a positive Orson
basically so you're you're looking at uh
those functions with non-negative values
or positive values and that defines a
convex parameter in this positive
percent of functions
and the third one is
we can actually drop off the symmetric
assumption so because it's a bipartite
graph
um without even without the Symmetry
assumption we can naturally Define this
function over here by giving a direction
from A to B okay and then we can just do
the same thing
um for the spike reference or asymmetric
graphones and then it's actually
equivalent so this H defined in defining
a norm in this larger space is actually
equivalent to uh
the weekly domain property which we
originally have had for the symmetric
functions
okay this is uh one example of
um equivalence and let me just describe
how one can use this to
protect some problems so this also
connects to what Dan did with his
colleagues basically using refuting
convexity
okay so this is my uh result with uh BR
Nash UK who's now a Caltech
um let's so here's an example
so let's consider G as an N by n
symmetric Matrix or a blocked graph one
um then it forms a homogeneous
polynomial of degree
degree being the number of edges in age
so here's an example so this is a two
Edge path and if I count these two Edge
paths in this block graph phone or a two
by two Matrix then it corresponds to
this quadratic polynomial
and this quadratic polynomial we can
represent as a sum of squares
just like this
and yeah this sum of squares are
SoMo Spurs gives the the convexity so we
can say that H is quickly numbing Yeah
by using this but there are some graphs
that give non-convex polynomials for
example the K5 Pi minus C10 this guy
gives a non-convex polynomial at around
some point that we found or even a
generalization any kind of Twisted odd
cycles of four Cycles yeah these give a
non-convex polynomials so as a corollary
uh we did manage to prove this notorious
example is not weak-noming which was a
question by hatami
okay so this is one example application
and um for norming graphs which is a
stronger property we have more
interesting uh number of equivalents
so the first one is the definition uh H
is normally and lots is observation in
the book says that we can actually drop
off the absolute value because your
weighted H count
um
would be always non-negative
so this is lati's observation and the
our theorem um the theorem of myself
with prnss it is a strictly convex
parameter on the whole Vector space
rather than the positive Orient and the
fourth one is well we can actually yeah
again we can drop off this symmetry
assumption to move on to the larger
space of the
the asymmetric preference or bike
reference
and the last one is particularly
interesting I would say
so this says uh it defines a norm on the
vector space of complex valued functions
but here the last one is a little bit
incorrect because for complex norming
let's say we need some two Edge coloring
of our age to assign these conjugates
to the values yeah so this was already
um this has been used by gowers
um
for his definition of octahedron Norms
or gowers Norms in these context of
additive promenatorics and it's actually
very natural to consider these complex
value functions because especially in
the context of the additive commercials
because if you take the Fourier
transform then it gives you a complex
valued function and yeah and if you
consider the inverse transform from
there then it will also give you a
complex valued function right
right so
um
this is my precise statement uh with
Sasha sirenko saying that a graph is
complex norming if and only if it is
Normie which means there exists a two
Edge coloring uh that allows us to
define a norm for this larger space of
complex value functions so yeah so this
is the precise formula that we can take
looks a little scary but I mean this
Alpha is just some zero one valued
function for each Edge and if I take
Alpha to be one then I take
non-conjugate and if Alpha is zero then
I take the conjugate so this is the
formula
yeah and here's an example again for a
full cycle so if I color my full cycle
in such a
alternating way then yeah this
corresponds to this average with complex
valued functions and that also
corresponds to the uh the force uh the
the shutter Norm
um
or the phone Norm of the Spectrum in the
complex setting
okay so why is this interesting because
we can actually use this theorem to
prove something about Nomine graphs
so we can actually prove that this Alpha
must be unique up to isomorphism and
moreover it's very very symmetric so we
can we can extract some combinatorial
properties of alpha to use it to apply
it to different problems uh to
distinguish these normal graphs and weak
gnoming graphs and prove something is
not normally something like that so
one theorem of ours says that there
exists uniquely exists a transitive
twitch coloring which means there is a
color preserving automorphism on
Minecraft H and there is also a color
reversing automorphism on H so by using
this fact we can prove various things
and moreover these Alpha colors each
shortage cycle in either monochromatic
way or like half halfway which means I'm
using the red color for the half the
edges and the blue color for the rest of
Legends
and it must also maximize the number of
alternating shortage cycles for example
if you look at this example so this is
precisely uh the two Edge coloring
that makes the one subdivision of
octahedron normally and you can actually
see that all these six Cycles which are
shortest Cycles are colored in an
alternating way so red blue red blue red
blue yeah so this must be the case for
every such colors
okay so here's one example application
um so let me just prove this fact so if
H is normal then there exists a balanced
to Edge coloring which means every
vertex sees the same number of red blue
colors okay
yeah so what I can do is to take this
complex value function so by X by using
this complex value function what I can
do is uh well if I if I count my
H in this particular
um Alpha coloring then yeah then what I
get is just this formula where my D1 and
d0 denotes the color the number of
colors that my vertex B sees okay and
yeah it's a standard effect that if uh
if this D1 minus d0 is non-zero then
this integral is zero so what it says is
if this is non-zero then we have both
the
um H count in F conjugate and F are zero
and and hence we have a non-zero real
value function which gives zero for this
H count but if you think about the
definition of norms
um this is not allowed so which
contradicts the the real norming
property of H so this is one example
application where we can say well well
there's a kind of symmetric
balance um two Edge coloring of H
yeah so this is one example application
and we apply this result to prove
various
um necessary conditions for the norming
property for example
we can actually prove that this G1 d2g
broth I mean every Nomine graph is
weakenoming and hence H transitives and
hence it's a G1 G2G graph so the game is
what we can say about these groups so
for example we can say that g has an
index two subgroup
so which is non-trivial
um I mean of course not every group has
a index 2 subgroup and if you take a
finite reflection group then there's a
very natural way to take a index 2
subgroup for example in the alternating
group you can just take your uh in the
symmetric group you can just take the
alternating subgroup which is index two
and this just generalizes to all Define
and reflection groups namely you can
just take those words
um that have even length yeah then that
forms a index 2 subgroup so this
corollary can be seen as an evidence for
this Grand classification conjecture
and our method also answered the last
outstanding questions question of hatami
so hatami actually left like six
questions and many of them answered by
um like Dan and colleagues and myself
and and so on and the last outstanding
question was whether this D Dimension
hypercube which were proven by hatami to
be weakernoming are norming or not and
we answer this question so whenever D is
greater than 2 this is not norming and
when these two this is just full cycle
which is a typical example of Nomine
graph so yeah we are done with
hypercubes
and there are other applications of the
result
um saying we try to classify the
bipartite knessographs
which means we on one hand we collect
the r subsets of some nset and on the
other side we collect its complement and
we put on edge if they are disjoint so
this is a bipartite version of
knessograph and we actually classified
all the older classic graphs and one
subdivision of KT is another example and
more generally we try to classify all
these set incidence graphs I and KR
which means we collect the case set over
R subsets from my end set and then
uh make the set incidence graph set
incidence bipartite graph out of them
um well we are quite close but the list
is not complete yet
um for the set inclusion verbs so yeah
there are loads of examples uh example
applications by using this complex
Nomine property
okay so let me how much time do I have
yeah
okay yeah so let me just wrap up
um
by introducing some open problems
um so one question is can we classify
all the normal reflection parts
so reflection graphs are known to be
weakness but distinguishing between
these weak norming and gnoming property
um yeah it's an interesting question
um and the
more applications of the weakness
property especially the correlation
inequality I showed yeah this inequality
has been useful in various different
contexts especially in the theory of
Quasi Randomness or the common graphs or
other even Other Extreme or graph
theoretic questions like
supersaturations or even the extremal
number or two round number itself for
the bipartite crops yeah it it has been
applied in various different contexts so
I would love to see more
and um another question is is there a
stable cut involution in a weak normal
graph which means so in a reflection
graph
the the geometric reflection themselves
corresponds to a very natural involution
on the graph for example you can see
these blue parts and red part in this
six cycle
corresponds to each other by say this
reflection along this
um yeah along this cut and there are
other other examples of such involutions
for reflection graphs so
um if the ground conjecture the grant
classification collector is true then it
this must be true but no one ever so far
managed to prove that there exists one
such involution which can be seen as an
Evidence of the existence of the
reflection reflection in the graph and
this also connects to the the positive
graph conductor which states that
if I consider
this H count in the weight setting and
if it's non-negative for any
um possibly negative W then it implies
there exists some
kind of mirror type symmetry
in this graph H so which we call the
stable involution for example you can
see one example in this six cycle where
if you want to count the six cycle in
the weighted setting what you can do is
basically fix your two vertices and take
the take the average
um the weighted average of the path of
length 2 and just Square it
so because of this Square structure no
matter how you uh choose your weighted
graph W uh the six cycle count must be
non-negative and the positive graph
conjecture states that this
the converse must be also true which
means if we have non-negative H count
for every weighted W then your H must
have such an evolution
um therein
yeah it's it's mostly an independent set
yeah so this in particular is not a
stable involution
in this
some positive graph conjecture is a
beautiful problem and in the paper by uh
in in the paper where this conjecture
appeared uh this case of Nomine graph
appeared was mentioned as a particular
interesting case and if there exists a
stable involution In Nomine graphs then
it basically proves the positive graph
conjecture for nucleus
okay so this is it thanks for listening
okay so yeah very nice talk I guess just
two small questions so I guess in
probability you know there's like this
uh moment uh question which is like what
if I give you a sequence of numbers uh
does it uniquely determine the and I
tell you some moments of a distribution
does that tell you that uh does it
uniquely determine the distribution so I
guess this is called the hamburger
moment problem and so I think this is
sort of remarkable you're saying that in
this space of graph font if you have
like finitely many moments in some sense
it's sort of uniquely determines
graphons
but so I have two questions so one is uh
what why what is this why should a
non-expert care about this weekly
norming versus norming like what's the
importance of this problem
um so the way I see is uh
whether you can
um Define some some age count in a
global sense you can define a convex
parameter globally on the space of in
the vector space or you you just
restrict yourself onto the the positive
or sent or the convex set of graph
phones
so this yeah so the way I see this
problem is a uh challenge to convexity
that we've been using and yeah these
lots of convexity inequalities in these
graph limits context
um has been very useful in attacking say
silver enclosed conjecture or
um even these uh like lower tail problem
um in this dense graph dense random
graph setting
um yeah yeah so it it or the proof of
some of this regular dilemma yeah so
it's been useful for various contexts
um so it's I think it's in general very
important to understand the the
strongest possible convexity inequality
um yeah in such a way yeah and yeah and
this question really connects to such a
philosophy okay thank you and the second
question is so you there were some some
of these results which seem to say
um you know if you want to prove
something for like graphs so sort of
symmetric graphs somehow if you prove
equivalent things for bipart type graphs
yes then they're kind of equivalent is
there any intuition like why you can
move between
like you know normal symmetric graphs
and sort of bipartite graphs
um
yeah I mean we were kind of surprised
yeah so the thing was the the known
technique before the theorem
um worked both in these asymmetric
setting and the symmetric setting so we
kind of suspected that they might be
equivalent yeah but
um
yeah but it just worked and as an
application it also simplified
um some of the known results for example
the atamis by regularity theorem if you
pass to the bike reference I think it's
just two lines
yeah yeah so
yeah I would say just heuristic
um like experience from like applying
these techniques to people thanks
um so this may follow from uh you know
many of the results that you stated but
uh apart from the Cycles are there so
are the complete bipartite graphs are
they norming the strongest one not the
norming uh so if you assume both sides
are of even size right yeah then they
are normally yeah so there there's some
parity issue there because in nobing
graphs uh domain graphs are necessarily
um eulerian which means every vertex
must have even degree nice yeah so yeah
it could be bipartite graphs must be
um yeah and then yeah thank you and
there seems to be a lot of references is
there a good monograph or was there a
starting point
um so for that I would say my paper with
with Sid renko is the most recent one so
it should include
um like as many references possible so
far yeah thank you
it seems to me that norming is much more
stronger than immediately normally is it
possible that actually for norming the
characterization is true that it comes
from a stable reflection groups while
the for weekly norming it is not true I
mean so it's not clear that one of the
contractors is true and the other is no
I
don't know
um but my I believe this classification
conjecture is true yeah so that's my
belief I mean when I wrote this paper
with David we we were not brave enough
to conjecture that the the examples we
found are just
all all of them but um yeah after years
and years we we tried many things and we
found new necessary conditions and it
kind of suggests that
um yeah if the conjecture uh could be
true
I believe so
questions
okay thank you again and let's have
coffee
[Applause]